I saw an episode that you well not an
episode but I saw that um whatever
podcast that you did I wanted to ask you
about that on the show as well
um because we exchanged some brief um
you know comments on that too by email
but
um
I've seen this trend now where podcasts
and I did this video I know that you
watched the whole thing because you saw
the shout out that I did in there but
you know I've seen this trend just for
people that are watching that aren't
familiar with that concept that where
there's a lot of podcasts now that sort
of have just come up and it's tables set
down and it seems to
rely on putting a bunch of people at a
table
when they put women at the table it
doesn't seem like they're picking the
best from you know the available
inventory of women that are out there on
the sexual Marketplace and it's let's
make bimbos look dumb I guess it's
probably the best way to summarize it
you sat down at one of these podcasts at
this table and I only watched the clips
I didn't watch the full podcast from
beginning to end but there's a few times
I could tell when you were sitting there
and it's like the professional in the
room looks a little bit uncomfortable
with some of these
questions and the way you know the
conversation was going what's your
thought as a professional when you know
now that you've sat in one of those
tables and you've seen some of these
obviously
these podcasts like what's your feelings
on that
I'm curious well I'm happy to have done
the experience it was a strange one for
me I have to admit I told this to Brian
the host of whatever that I hadn't seen
an episode of whatever before when he
reached out and I did some very cursory
research and I looked at a couple of
episodes some clips I watched maybe five
minutes and what I saw in these clips
was there's like four or five guys on
one side of the table four or five women
on the other and they're actually having
a discussion about relationships in
their sexual Dynamics I was like oh that
sounds interesting because you know the
men are actually saying these things to
the women's face and the women get a
chance to respond to them and I thought
that that was an interesting Dynamic
rather than just guys just sort of
spouting off into their Echo Chambers
it's actually a dialogue and I thought
okay I could I could sign up for that
and so I decided to go down to do the
podcast now on the episode that you did
I didn't watch the whole thing I just
sort of skimmed around and I'm not
surprised that you didn't watch the
whole whatever podcast I was surprised
that it went on for five hours it was an
endurance challenge for me
I I can't believe that there might have
been people who sat through the whole
thing it was hard for me sometimes it's
common and it draws a lot of eyeballs
which is somewhat surprising it's like
the whole like the car crash people
always look at the car crash when
they're driving on the highway and it
and it almost seems like this is what
we're watching for five hours sure and
in your episode on that podcast you
mentioned Jerry Springer a bunch of
times yeah now Brian received me very
well when I went down to Santa Barbara
to be on the podcast we had a phone
conversation before I went on and he
called the podcast the Jerry Springer
Show of YouTube so I think Brian is
I don't know him very well I just met
him that one time but I think he's
self-aware about what he's doing yeah I
think that he is intentionally choosing
women who their Optics look unusual
because that's going to be provocative
or interesting he's definitely in
entertainment and I don't think that he
um has any Illusions about what he's
doing as far as I can tell
yeah I mean the Optics of the whole
thing was you know there's a Asian girl
sitting in the back corner with a a
spiky hat petting a little black baby
and there's a woman dressed up as a cat
you know opposing the table and everyone
talks about the girl with the baby but
she was behind me so I couldn't see what
she was doing the whole time but that's
it was it was distracting because I'm
watching the professional talk and sort
of you know explain Concepts and I see
this girl over your shoulder making
bizarre faces almost talking to herself
stroking a black baby doll sort of thing
with a little spiky hat and I thought to
myself
wow
um Brian referred to her as the mascot
so which is there because it's it's like
a baseball game it's five hours long and
there's going to be a lot of down time
and so she's there to kind of keep the
audience engaged
so the Jerry Springer of YouTube at
least they understand what they're doing
okay that podcast started a year ago and
it has over 4 million subscribers which
is incredible well I mean In fairness
the channel when you look at it from the
older videos it it was mostly a prank
channel so they would use the telephoto
lens with a wired up you know wireless
mic and they would prank people you know
at a distance and record it and sure
he told me that too and yeah he's he's
it's all founded in entertainment and I
don't think that he thinks that he's
doing anything but that do you think
there's any use in the content that's
being created for guys because it would
seem to be mostly guys I mean judging by
the live chats that they're dealing with
um is there any benefit to men watching
five hours of the back and forth between
men and women orchestrated in a
I mean it's not as bad as Jerry Springer
where you know security has to come
running out and separating people from
fights but people do get thrown off the
show they get removed they get put in uh
Checkmate there's always you know click
baby type of thumbnails where like you
know she was triggered or something like
that there's an arrow point into
somebody with a strange face how does
how do you recommend guys and navigate
that so they get benefit from it I guess
is you know the way that I'm trying to
phrase this question and make it useful
or is it even possible to do that
I've thought about this a little bit
because you got podcasts like whatever
and you got fresh and fit and they're
they're both very very popular and they
both
play with red pill intersexual Dynamics
and they're they have extremely high
viewership and so I thought well what
what is really going on here and the
best I can come up with among other
things is
it it's kind of a a male fantasy because
when you turn into these shows you can
generally expect that the men if they're
not going to win
they're going to be made to look really
good
and oftentimes sometimes they have these
ridiculous looking folks on these
podcasts but they also have really
traditionally attractive women too you
got
smoke shows in tight cocktail dresses
and the fantasy is that you have these
men
who are telling them that they're wrong
who are telling them that they're
they're actually not getting what they
want is like they're they're they're
beating them in a dialogue about
relationships and I think that's like
very vicariously satisfying to a lot of
male viewers who might not even have the
courage to approach one of these women
in everyday life if they were to see
them they can tune in and listen to guys
put these really attractive women in
their place and I think that's part of
the the male fantasy that
supports the their viewership I would
agree with that so is it is it bimbos
being made to look dumb is that what
they are
well again it's complicated I was after
that recording
I did chat briefly with a couple of the
women who are on that episode and they
also didn't seem to be
like
just like Brian seemed to know what he
was doing that he was kind of a Jerry
Springer Show the women kind of knew
what they were doing and they talked
about their social media like their
podcast personas
and they were playing up parts of
themselves so that they could
potentially
be invited to more podcasts I don't know
what they get out of it maybe they get
free tickets or hotel rooms I'm not sure
but I mean I think it's exposure for
their social media and their only fans
if they have one it could very well be
and I think that those women are they
see it as a business opportunity so I
I'm not quite sure to what extent they a
lot of those women are let's say
authentically
presenting themselves I think it could
be a persona do you think it's an
accurate representation of the female
demographic that's out there today
on like women in the sexual Marketplace
or on only fans no uh like on these
podcasts like do you think these women
that are showing up on these podcasts
are an accurate representation of the
general female population out there no I
I don't but sometimes they
it's like science sometimes studies
really extreme habitats because it's
under these conditions that we can see
more Universal truths about life like if
life can Thrive here in these
environments then maybe we can learn
something that's universally true and so
maybe one of the the didactic
takeaways of these podcasts is these
women are extreme examples and we can
see in these extreme examples some
principles that may be
that may be present to a lesser degree
universally among women or even among
people but it's easier to see in these
extreme examples
yeah it's it's uh it's a fascinating
um Dynamic that's only Arisen the last
couple years I like I think Howard Stern
is probably the closest thing that you
might relate it to like he might be the
OG or even Tom lycus are you familiar
with Tom Leykis no but I met Howard
Stern a few times and yeah he's a nice
guy when I was an actor I actually was
doing a show with his daughter she was
my love interest so I made out with
Howard Stern's daughter on stage um
every night and he was a great dad he
would come so he came to the show
multiple times and it was not only
strange to meet the celebrity but also
that I was hooking up with his daughter
so I'll uh I'll share a story with you
after we come off there remind me when
we end the show because I can't talk
about it live but
um yeah it's it's like you know the
whole Howard Stern Tom like like Tom
lycus was probably one of the first guys
that were because he ran a radio show
right so there's no video of it but
there's mostly like loads and loads of
audio recordings out there so if you
search on YouTube for Tom lycus you'll
see a lot of these playbacks where it's
like he's dealing with people calling in
and they're asking questions about
dating a lot of the stuff that you know
you and I even have covered today or in
the past few years years you know
something that's been talked about
before and I'm sure it's been you know
it was talked about in the 50s 60s and
70s by other people I just don't know
who but like the sit-down podcast sort
of uh thing that has just happened is
it's bizarre in the sense where it's
like
I see the car crash I'm watching it
unfold in slow motion literally over
five hours if you watch the whole thing
and then you're right I think a lot of
the people that are watching it
especially the guys it's like this like
Vindication like this validation like
the AHA gotcha you know sort of thing
and I think that's what draws them in
and I don't know like I'm still
struggling I guess at this point you
know as we're talking about it to
at least offer some kind of benefit
solution uh use case for guys aside from
that like Vindication like you know
gotcha betchino sort of thing which
seems to be the angle
I'm just wondering if it even exists I
don't know I mean it could just be pure
entertainment I mean not everything has
to be have a nutritional value as it
were people binge all kinds of reality
shows on TV then I don't know if they
really help people become better
versions of themselves
you might because I always look for the
nutritional value that's maybe that's
just my perspective of things I mean
Brian did try to bring some things he
talked about the divorce rates and the
way that men kind of get shafted in the
court system the fresh and fit guys they
have good points so maybe if men haven't
really heard about the red pill before
this could be a way that they get
exposed to some of these ideas I'm not
sure good all right um so let's move on
for that so let me ask you a question
about marriage then so you're a single
guy or do you have a girlfriend like
what's your status right now I'm seeing
somebody but I'm unmarried awesome so
would you ever get married knowing what
you know about family law and about the
Dynamics between men and women in the
modern world today I wouldn't say never
but I would be very cautious around
getting married for a number of reasons
I've seen divorce up close I'm the child
of divorce uh my father was the child of
divorce
my parents divorce took three years it
was extremely painful
how old were you when they went through
it I was 15. okay
and in large part because of that
divorce my dad spent his 50s and part of
his 60s in a one-room studio apartment
and that's how he had to live
and this is a man who my mother worked
maybe a year or two in her life who
cared and took and provided for me and
my sister and my mother and and this was
his reward at the end of the the day
so I see how divorce can destroy men's
lives here in California I've worked
with a number of guys navigate their
divorces it takes
at least a year and a half you pay for
the the woman's lawyer there's no
incentive that this is going to be an
easy quick process
um
it's and there's a lot of incentives my
point
is
I'm not really sure what guys get out of
marriage like the actual legal contract
you can have a long-term committed
relationship without marriage you can
have children without marriage like the
arguments
you know it used to that used to not
really be the case but that's maybe one
of the benefits of the modern age is
that we can kind of deconstruct marriage
and we can we can take the things that
we want and leave the rest
I have this this idea that like
well I think marriage is primarily for
the security of a woman
and I think that made more sense when
women
couldn't or wouldn't in make their own
money and now in the modern day a lot of
women are doing extraordinarily well
women under 30 who are childless are
generally out earning men in that same
demographic
the idea that
um
that women need the security of that
relationship
is I think a little bit outdated I think
it has to do with their diminishing
sexual Marketplace value and their need
for let's say companionate love which
might be greater in women than it is for
men
I like Patrice O'Neill's take on it
which is that men generally
they want women to be they men want to
be alone but not by themselves so they
kind of they want their own space and
they want the women kind of around and
to me that works out great
so I live by myself I am have had
long-term committed relationships and my
girlfriends have they they know my
positions on marriage so if they're
gonna stick it around
it's because potentially there's enough
value left over for them to uh to do so
um
and I think for a lot of women if the
relationship is strong
they're willing to forego the the legal
contract
I think that's one of the first things
they're willing to dispense with
yeah I mean I've said this
quite a few times privately on consults
and with guys in my uh group and we have
discussions about this sort of thing and
surprisingly
women will abandon their demands and
parts of their sexual strategy and adopt
yours if they see you as a high enough
value guy sure
um that being said marriage can be
avoided
um you can still have relationships with
women like you know for myself I'm in a
non-cohabitating LTR I've been with my
gal for years she's awesome we live in
two separate houses sometimes you know
we live together on you know short short
stints for a vacation whatever but then
there comes a question for guys also
because let's be honest I mean the
reason why we're walking this Earth is a
scattered seed and to pass on our DNA
it's like okay now how do you have
children
so I guess the next question for you sir
is
do you want to have kids and if you did
what is your strategy for doing that to
minimize the risks well I go back and
forth so I'm I'm at the place where I
feel like I will only move forward if
it's an enthusiastic yes on my end and
I'm not there yet because I've seen
among my I'm the only unmarried
childless friend that I have in my
friend group and so I've seen what
happens to men once they get married and
really when they have kids and
I don't see them that much anymore they
spend half of their waking lives earning
money and the other half of their lives
taking care of the kids and
the wife and just being domesticated
a lot of these men love it and if that
works for them
fantastic they love their little family
lives and that's what they've dreamed
about since they were young men and they
got it great I hope it works out for
them
what I've also seen though is that the
amount of sacrifice required in terms of
time energy and money to have uh one
woman and to have
a family is considerable and I think
about like I'm working on a book would I
be able to write a book if I had a kid
um would I be able to travel the world
if I wanted to have a kid I think it's
possible but it's it's much much harder
and you need a lot of money to do it and
also a flexible open-minded committed
woman who's willing to kind of roll with
it and occupy that place in your frame I
really hope you guys enjoyed that clip
if you want to watch the full-length
podcast you can find that over here that
clips from if you're newer to the
channel make sure you hit subscribe over
here and pin down below in the top
comment you'll find a bunch of useful
links to my website my supplement line
books and a bunch of other stuff have an
amazing day peace out